empecemos hablando de que cambio de
colombia luego del paro nacional
buenas noches muy claras para responder
a esta pregunta creo que ese cambio no
no no es un cambio que se puede haber
inmediatamente es un cambio más bien que
se ha venido dando de manera paulatina y
creo que es una sociedad mucho más
madura en términos políticos que
participa de manera mucho más activa y
que le ha perdido el temor a la
movilización social algo que daba temor
en colombia durante muchos años y queda
demostrado que por esa vía se pueden
alcanzar en muchas cosas y muchas
demandas sociales se pueden satisfacer
también por esa vía y el descontento
social que se mostró durante el paro
está lo suficientemente fuerte como para
influir en las elecciones presidenciales
de este año o ya perdió fuerza yo creo
que está descontento social se mantiene
sobre todo porque el gobierno nacional
ha sido tremendamente ineficiente a la
hora de responder las demandas que tenía
buena parte de la ciudadanía y que son
demandas que no vienen únicamente del
paro de 2021 sino recordemos que
habíamos tenido un primer momento de
movilización muy al isi con el gobierno
educa en 2019 y luego tuvimos una serie
movilizaciones a lo largo de 2020 de
distintos sectores de los sectores de
algunos pueblos indígenas mujeres
comerciantes en bogotá recordemos la
masacre de bogotá de septiembre y esto
ciertamente ha deja un descontento que
además es un descontento muy diverso y
que no se pueden catalogar como de un
único sector en boga en colombia perdón
sino que es un sector esos son distintos
sectores los que tienen distintos
descontentos y eso ciertamente se va a
traducir en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales sin que eso signifique
que haya una preferencia predeterminada
por aquellas personas y por aquellos
ciudadanos que se movilizaron durante
este periodo y usted habla de las
manifestaciones de años anteriores en
ese sentido cuál fue la particularidad
del paro nacional de 2021 en comparación
con otras movilizaciones sociales en
colombia
yo creo que la particularidad de este
paro es que logra sostenerse en el
tiempo el paro de 2019 se interrumpe
pues primero porque llegará navidad por
un intento muy muy vago de negociación
del gobierno nacional y luego pues viene
la pandemia el paro 2021 recoge buena
parte de lo que se había demandado en
ese momento y logró sostenerse durante
varios meses no porque a la gente le
guste movilizarse como si no tuviera
nada mejor que hacer en sus vidas sino
porque el descontento se acumuló a lo
largo de la pandemia la respuesta del
estado fue fue tremendamente pues brutal
es que en las imágenes lo estamos viendo
la brutalidad policial con la que se
respondió e inmediatamente eso también
se convierte en una bandera la demanda
por el respeto a los derechos humanos
por el respeto a los jóvenes por el
respeto el derecho a la protesta y eso
empezó a alimentar de cierta forma la
manifestación que se sostuvo en el
tiempo como digo pero no solamente
porque la gente salió constantemente
sino también porque se lograron
construir unos discursos políticos se
logra construir también una yo diría que
una agenda mucho más sólida no porque
haya un sector organizado propiamente
sino porque más bien a partir de estos
distintos sectores sociales logran
organizarse en colombia'